so tonight it is not just big tech that
is fueling cancel culture around the
country
america's major corporations they are
playing a significant role
now after the left vilified unfairly and
inaccurately georgia's new
election legislation that made voting
far more accessible in jo than joe
biden's home state of delaware
well you know the consequences major
league baseball pulled its all-star game
from the state of georgia now other
corporations
major ones vowed to take actions and
major studios in hollywood claim that
they would boycott the entire state of
georgia
all because of a lie from democrats led
by joe biden
who kept calling this jim crow 2.0 again
georgia that makes it far more
accessible for voting than delaware
and by the way they include 17 days of
early voting
every precinct every county has these
boxes you can drop your ballots in
the state of delaware has none of that
so the question now
becomes tonight why are these major
corporations
now ready and willing to get political
placate the radical left and do so
ignorantly without any of the facts and
what should republicans do about it
you can also blame stacey abrams for a
lot of this happening
here now with more south carolina
senator lindsey graham senator
i look at this 17 days early voting
in georgia uh in personally voting zero
in the state of delaware you want an
absentee ballot you have to provide an
excuse
that's not the case in georgia uh drop
boxes
all over georgia none are in delaware
and both have voter id laws
so how does joe biden especially with
his race history himself
uh dare to make the allegation
time after time this is jim crow 2.0 and
look at the financial devastation
that occurred thereafter
well they're trying to intimidate
corporate america to
abandon the republican party and here's
my message to corporate america
corporate georgia have you lost your
mind don't you realize that the only
thing between
you and your companies and your
shareholders
and the democratic agenda of high taxes
incredible regulations and unbelievable
spending is the republican party don't
you realize that the republican
uh georgia of the two democrats
in georgia in the united states senate
are fully on board for the most radical
agenda
in the history of the country when it
comes to tax spending and regulation
so they're intimidated here's what
happened two days ago
when i was in georgia speaking to the
annual republican party fundraising
dinner
for the republican party of georgia 18
corporations who gave money last year
decided not to give a dime this year
only one corporation in georgia helped
the republican party georgia power
they lost 150 000 dollars because
corporations in georgia have been
intimidated
by this idea of jim crow 2.0 so i'm
going to give 75
000 from my campaign to the georgia
republican party who we're going to need
to take the senate seat back in georgia
and i'm asking people they handed the
army that's always helped me
see if you can chip in a few bucks to
help the georgia republican party make
up
for the money they lost because of this
boycott by corporate america
of conservatives in georgia go to
lindsey graham.com
it will send you to the georgia gop site
you can
you can help make up the money they were
lost that was lost because
corporate america is being intimidated
by the left
i like the idea herschel walker was
recently on this program yes
apparently moved back to georgia
interesting
timing um and he is he is
open to running against uh warnock
in 2022. yeah now i happen to be a fan
of herschel walker
and not just hershel walker the football
player i like herschel walker the man
the person the human being and i think
he'd be a great senator from georgia
and i think warnock and i think stacey
abrams i think the democratic party
in georgia they have a lot of explaining
to do as well as corporations like delta
and coca-cola
well let me just put it this way when
you look at senator warnack's voting
record
he's down for the green new deal he's
for court packing he's for eliminating
the filibuster
he's for the uh massive tax increase
he's for six trillion dollars more of
spending he's for everything that aoc
is for so if you have a chance in
georgia
to replace him with a herschel walker
and you're a ceo of a company
who depends on free enterprise to make a
living and you don't see the benefit of
a republican in georgia
you should be fired you've lost your
mind if you can't understand the
difference between where
herschel walker would take corporate
america and free enterprise versus
senator warnock you should lose your job
and shareholders should be all over
these companies
for abandoning the company who needs
free enterprise less regulation less
taxes
to flourish i see that there is the
emergence now of a new democratic party
and a new republican party
and and there's a certain desperation i
think within the democratic ranks that
if we have
well let's see free fair elections which
would include voter id
uh chain of custody partisan observers
observing
you clean up the roles you know just the
fundamental signature verification those
five things
they seem threatened but there is a
lieutenant governor of the state of
north carolina that i know you're fond
of
that i think would make a great senate
candidate from that state
there are two unbelievably amazing
african-american women in
pennsylvania that are likely going to
make a run for the senate there
i think both can win that state and i
would love to be able to support both of
them
it looks like the democratic party they
want to be the party of coastal elites
go for it
yeah i would just say to my republican
colleagues can we move forward
uh without president trump the answer is
no
i've always liked liz cheney but she's
made a determination that the republican
party
can't can't grow with president trump
i've determined we can't grow without
him all of these people like hershel
walker and all the people you
just named are attracted to the trump
republican party
economic populism america first agenda
if you don't get that as a republican
you're making the biggest mistake in the
history of the republican party
the reason our party is growing with
minorities and with working men and
women is because president trump
appears to be on the side of people
working really hard
appears to be on the side of opportunity
not dependency
because he is so i just want to tell
everybody if you want to help
take back this seat in georgia stand up
to corporate america
let's make up the money the georgia
republican party lost
i'm in for 75 000 help me get the other
75 000 to the georgia republican party
lindsey graham.com
we're not going to be held hostage by
these people
i donate but every time i donate money
to any political cause i get yelled at
by my bosses
you can do this you can do this hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else